à en voyant ce passage j'ai tout de
suite ressenti une très forte empathie
pour ce jeune homme qui contemple des
heures de travail réduites à néant
et dans ce contexte harrison ford ma
part et au mieux comme un grossier
personnage voire carrément comme un
sacré connard mais d'une façon qui
m'étonne moi même je ne peux m'empêcher
d'être déçus mais déçu de quoi au juste
à bien y réfléchir je pense que ma
déception vient du décalage entre le
comportement d'harrison ford sur ce
plateau et l'image mentale que je
m'étais fait de lui cette image elle
s'est construite lors des diverses
apparitions publiques de l'acteur que
j'ai pu voir par ci par là mais aussi à
travers ses rôles cinématographiques
gelé vu comme un loubard égoïste au
grand coeur en aventurier pilleurs de
tombes au sang chaud ou un détective
taciturne assaillie de doutes
autant d'apparitions qui ont construit
une image plus ou moins cohérente faite
d'éléments positifs comme le courage
l'humour est évidemment une classe
inimitable mais aussi d'éléments moins
positifs comme un certain égoïsme
solitaire et un rapport à tout le moins
discutable avec la gente féminine
cela dit je sais bien que ce ne sont que
des rôles et qu'harrison ford n'a
peut-être rien à voir avec ces
personnages il a même passé une bonne
partie de sa carrière à essayer de se
mettre à distance acquérant ainsi une
solide réputation de troll en ne ratant
jamais une occasion de désacraliser ses
oeuvres de la pop culture que des
milliers de fans portent au pinacle
d'une façon quasi religieuse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on pourrait donc penser qu'il n'y a
aucun lien entre l'acteur et les
personnages qu'il peut jouer mais au
contraire le fait de se moquer des fans
de désacraliser ce qui fait la duration
des foules rentrent parfaitement en
adéquation avec le bad boy iconoclaste
qui l'a si souvent incarné à l'écran
pareillement lorsqu'il prétend de faire
ces films que pour l'argent on est assez
proches du en solo que l'on découvre au
début du premier star wars en
contrebande y écouler égoïstes qui ne
fait rien sans rien oui sauf que voilà
c'est sensible ce truc sauf que dans la
suite du film
le franc-tireur s'amende au contact des
autres il apprend à laisser de côté son
ego et revient à la fin du film pour
sauver tout le monde et si par la suite
il retombera parfois dans ses travers
initiaux nous les spectateurs
nous savons que c'est surtout de la mise
en scène pour caché son attachement réel
et le fait est que je m'aperçois que
j'ai transposé sur l'acteur cette
évolution du personnage
quand je vois harrison ford cracher sur
la saga je ne le prends en fait jamais
complètement au premier degré et je la
presse est davantage comme enjeu avec le
public
et là vient cette séquence où à mon sens
on dépasse le simple trolls et jean
vient brutalement à reconsidérer ce que
je crois savoir sur l'acteur je précise
que je n'ai aucune idée du contexte
précis de cette séquence
et connaissant les plateaux américains
il est fort possible que tout ne soit
qu'une mise en scène humoristique
destiné à entretenir laura
je-m'en-foutiste de ford
cela dit ça ne change en rien la
réflexion que je voulais partager avec
vous sur nos rapports entre le jeu
d'acteur et la réalité sociale
aujourd'hui on va parler de rôle et de
cinéma alors installez vous
confortablement et laissez vous porter
on va commencer par revenir sur la
notion de rôle dans les sciences
sociales avant de bifurquer vers des
chemins moins balisés pour interroger le
parallèle que l'on peut faire avec les
rôles cinématographiques
[Musique]
en sociologie la notion de rôle se
définit comme l'ensemble des
comportements que la société attend
d'une personne en fonction de son statut
un individu va donc cumuler plusieurs
rôles au cours d'une vie voire même au
sein d'une même journée on peut passer
du rôle d'utilisatrices des transports a
doctor dans une clinique avant de
devenir une petite amie magnifique
sublime girl puis une maman responsable
et affectueuse pour ensuite revenir
élèves dans le cadre son cours de danse
ou lead chanteuse dans un groupe du
gangsta rap activistes politiques dans
un groupuscule anarchiste ou carrément
sénatrice intergalactique avec tout le
décorum que cela suppose les
possibilités sont infinies
dans cette triste hic le monde social
est alors assimilé à une scène sur
laquelle prennent place les individus
qui joue un certain nombre de rôles
sociaux
cette image l'avantagé de permettre une
vision plus dynamique plus interactive
de la socialisation
elle permet aussi de retranscrire une
partie de la complexité attachée à
chaque individu
nous ne sommes pas des marionnettes
actionné par les structures sociales
nous jouons des rôles et même si c'est
la société qui définit la grille des
comportements acceptables dans chaque
situation
nous sommes actifs dans la façon dont
nous nous engageons dans chacun de ses
rôles c'est ça la solution diplomatique
sénatrice
ça c'est de la négociation bus
l'un des premiers auteurs à s'être
intéressé à cette question c'est le
philosophe et psychosociologue george
herbert timide
pour la petite histoire c'est le papa de
l'anthropologue margaret midi dont
j'avais présenté certains travaux dans
cet épisode de ce seul quick en 1934
soit trois ans après sa mort paraît à
titre posthume son ouvrage le plus
célèbre l'esprit le soin et la société
dans lequel il énonce que l'enfant se
développe principalement par
l'appropriation de différents rôles
sociaux mais toi chérie où est ton
déguisement c'est ça mon déguisement je
suis un fou criminelle il ressemble à
n'importe qui au début
l'enfant unique les rôles de ce que me
d'appel les autrui significatif c'est à
dire ceux avec qui il est en contact et
qu'ils influencent directement
ils vont donc commencer par imiter des
rôles qu'ils arrivent à percevoir
ils vont jouer au papa et à la maman à
la maîtresse et globalement ils se font
une idée des différents rôles en
interagissant directement avec les gens
qui les incarnent
et puis petit à petit les enfants se
rendent compte de deux choses tout
d'abord que les autres rues significatif
ne se limite pas à leur rôle initial
mais qu'il change de comportement en
fonction des situations et ensuite ils
prennent conscience que le monde social
est en fait beaucoup plus vaste que leur
simple autrui significatif et que c'est
en fait une espèce de bouillasse informe
composé de plein de gens qui incarnent
des dizaines de rôles différents mais
que tous ces rôles suivent quand même à
peu près les mêmes règles générales me
d'appel cela l'autrui généralisée c'est
une abstraction qui incarne la
communauté organisée où le groupe social
structuré dont fait partie d'individus
et petit à petit les enfants n'agissent
plus simplement pour faire plaisir à
leurs proches mais pour se conformer à
ce que l'autre hui généralisée attend
d'eux qu'ils comprennent par exemple que
s'il gueule à s'en faire péter la rate
au milieu d'un centre commercial
ils vont plutôt recevoir des retours
négatifs de la part de tout le monde
et il commence justement à s'en soucier
de ce que les autres pensent d'eux et
par la suite 7 août rue généralisée par
l'apport hockey dont se construit on
l'intègre en fait dans un coin de notre
esprit de sorte que même quand on est
tout seul on vient parfois à adopter les
comportements que l'on aurait s'ils ont
été observés on reste dans notre rôle
par suite pour mid la construction de
soi va dépendre de la façon dont nous
ont deux sont les différents rôles
sociaux il différencie donc deux
identités bien distinctes
le jeu est le mois où le mois ci notre
identité sociale celle qui existe dans
l'oeil des autres et qu'ils endossent
des rôles créés existants et où le jeu
c'est la façon que nous avons de réagir
à ce mois en quelque sorte c'est notre
identité psychologique qui peut l
adhérer ou rejeter les rôles imposée par
la société essaie de cet équilibre entre
le jeu et le mois que va naître notre
véritable identité
le soi et pour mid le soin d'un individu
n'est rien d'autre que la recherche
perpétuelle de stabilité entre le jeu et
le mois le jem ce qui se passe mais on
est d'accord c'est
c'est leur secret s'arrête un peu d'eau
oui non parce que les gens sont pas
obligées de savoir que les textes de
midi ils ont été largement repris en
sociologie notamment par le courant
constructiviste dont l' ouvrage le plus
connu est sans doute la construction
sociale de la réalité de peter berg
heures et thomas sluc man paru en 1966
cela dit je ne vais pas m'étendre
directement dessus parce que c'est un
ouvrage très théorique est plutôt touffu
je vais plutôt m'appuyer sur certains
passages de l'invitation à la sociologie
de peter berg heures paru en 1963 dans
lequel l'auteur reprend un certain
nombre de choses mais d'une façon
beaucoup plus accessible et il insiste
notamment sur la notion de rôle social
tu a adopté la noirceur soit mais moi je
suis né de la noirceur façonnée par elle
je n'ai jamais vu la lumière avant
d'être devenu un homme et elle ne
pouvait plus être pour moi ki moon pour
reprendre la vision de mid notre
identité se situe entre le jeu
psychologique et le mois sociale ce qui
implique que les rôle que nous jouons
peuvent influencer notre identité
tout dépend de la façon qu'a notre jeu
d'incarner ce rôle par exemple si je
porte une cravate pour la première fois
de ma vie pour aller à un mariage
je joue le rôle d'un mec en cravate pour
toute la soirée
ça c'est mon moi ce que je donne à voir
aux autres mais mon jeu intérieur il
peut se dire oh [ __ ] c'est chiant ce
truc ça sert et puis sa trempe dans la
soupe bon dès que je peux je l'enlève
ce qui suppose que le jeu ne se
considère pas du tout comme un mec à
cravate
donc ça va rester en roll al'inverse
certains rôles peuvent être assimilés
aussi bien par le mois que par le jeu et
ça repose en partie sur une certaine
habitude du rôle par exemple si je suis
avocat c'est évidemment le rôle que je
joue dans le monde du travail mais c'est
aussi typiquement le genre de métier où
il ya de très fortes chances que mon
eux se définisse lui aussi comme un
avocat par exemple que ce soit la
première chose que je dise quand je me
présente et donc que ce métier devienne
un support important de mon identité
c'est très souvent aussi le cas du genre
d'un point de vue sociologique
le genre est un rôle social comme un
autre il définit un ensemble de
comportements considérés comme
acceptables par une personne donnée de
nombreuses recherches sur la
socialisation enfantine montre comment
les parents sanctionne consciemment ou
non les comportements jugés non
conformes au sexe de l'enfant dans le
film boys don't cry de 1999 l'actrice
hilary swank joue le rôle d'un jeune
garçon transgenres et elle annonce que
pour entrer dans le rôle elle a dû faire
un long travail de préparation sachant
qu'il fallait qu'elle soit convaincante
dans un rôle masculin
elle a alors passé plusieurs mois à
sortir dans la rue habillé comme un
homme et quand quelqu'un lui disait
qu'il n'y croyait pas elle demandait
pourquoi afin d'ajuster dans son jeu ce
qui n'allait pas je trouve cet exemple
intéressant parce qu'il montre que même
des façons d'être très intériorisée
peuvent être comprises comme des rôles
dans lesquels nous nous sommes glissés
nous avons l'impression de marcher
normalement
pourtant il y à bien une façon féminine
et masculine de marché que nous avons
apprise sans nous en rendre compte et
qui a contribué à façonner notre
identité
j'aime me battre de là un acteur ou une
actrice qui travaillent en rôle doit
justement faire un travail
d'objectivation de ses façons d'être
incorporé un travail assez proche de
celui du sociologue en fin de compte
puisque justement il observe 10 sec et
analyse les façons d'être
mais la particularité de l'acteur c'est
qu'il reproduit ensuite ses façons
d'être mais cette fois sans les
intériorisé à long terme alors que dans
la vie les rôle que nous jouons ont une
influence sur notre personne vous avez
des tofs d'une mère de famille je peux
vous poser une question hubert bien sûr
vous me diriez tout ça si j'étais un
homme
il savait les hommes sont rarement et
oui
air de famille sur ce sujet peter berg
heures écrit ceci le rôle fourni à
l'individu un modèle pour agir dans une
situation donnée
dans la vie comme au théâtre les
instructions attaché au rôle sont plus
ou moins strictement définies prenons
par exemple le domaine des métiers dans
le rôle de l'éboueur le modèle à suivre
est assez simple tandis que les médecins
les prêtres ou les officiers de l'armée
doivent acquérir toutes sortes de
manières de faire bien particulière des
façons de parler et de se tenir comme un
maintien militaire une diction plein
d'options ou l'art de parler aux malades
mais on passerait à côté d'un aspect
essentiel si l'on ne voyait dans le rôle
qu un moyen régulant les actions
visibles de l'extérieur
plus on embrasse plus on devient
amoureux la fréquence des génuflexions
développe l'humilité et la colère
s'accroît à force de brandir le poing
autrement dit le baiser n'exprime pas
seulement l'ardeur amoureuse il l'a
créée la pratique des rôles débouche sur
des actes déterminés mais aussi sur les
émotions et les attitudes qui vont avec
le professeur qui se donnent l'air
savant fini par se sentir tél le
prédicateur on vient à croire elle ce
qu'ils prêchent le soldat sans battre
dans sa poitrine un choeur martial quand
il endosse son uniforme dans tous ces
exemples l'émotion ou l'attitude pouvait
être là avant que les personnages
n'entre dans leur rôle
mais celui ci renforce à coup sûr les
sentiments préexistants bien souvent
d'ailleurs il y a toutes raisons de
penser que rien de tout cela n'existait
dans la conscience de l'acteur avant
qu'il me joue son rôle
cette vision performatif du rôle social
est assez proche de la vision que
développe pierre bourdieu de l'habitus
ce système de dispositions régler qui
permettent à l'individu de se mouvoir
dans le monde social dispositions qui
sont par la suite intériorisée et
diffusée par l'acteur social qui devient
un vaisseau de leur reproduction
pour reprendre les termes de bourdieu
l'habitus est un ensemble de structures
structure est prédisposé à fonctionner
comme structure structurantes
l'idée principale étant que pour bien
jouer son rôle sur la scène sociale il
faut embrasser ce rôle oublier qu'il
s'agit d'une structure a prises pour
bien jouer le jeu il faut oublier qu'on
joue le jeu
[Musique]
c'est quelque chose qui me parlent
personnellement si on prend la figure du
professeur le professeur un minimum
informer sur l'institution scolaire par
exemple qui aurait lu la reproduction de
bourdieu et passeron sait pertinemment
que l'idéal méritocratique de l'école
n'est pas seulement le résultat de la
volonté républicaine d'égalité des
chances mais que c'est aussi devenu une
idéologie qui sert à justifier les
inégalités
ceux qui ont les places les plus envieux
dans la société seraient ceux qui ont
les mieux travailler à l'école et il ne
le devraient qu'à leur travail et leur
mérite personnel mais on sait aussi que
les élèves n'arrivent pas égaux devant
l'école est loin de combler les
inégalités initial elle leur permet bien
souvent de se perpétuer dans ce contexte
le professeur honnête avec lui-même ne
peut ignorer qu'il est un instrument de
la reproduction sociale alors même qu'il
est censé donner une chance égale à
chacun et cette dichotomie entre la
réalité et l'idéologie peut mener à de
grosses dissonance cognitive
c'est notamment ce que raconte maxime
mariette dans sa conférence d'instituts
les trans classe express ancien
professeur de philosophie issu d'un
milieu populaire
il ne pouvait supporter l'idée d'être
devenu un instrument de la reproduction
des inégalités scolaires et il a
finalement démissionné de son poste de
professeur et donc ce que le ce que l'on
fait quand on est prof c'est qu'on y est
rare qu'ils ont fait de la
discrimination discrimination ça veut
dire faire la différence
voilà ce qu'on faisait ont fait la
différence on fait la différence entre
ceux qui ont la bonne culture et ceux
qui ont la mauvaise culture l es s stg
tmg
voilà j'ai un vrai j'avais l'impression
de faire ça mais qu'en est il des autres
de ceux qui restent enseigner et bien on
peut dire qu'ils jouent le jeu
ils font comme si tous leurs élèves
avaient une chance non nul de réussite à
condition de travailler suffisamment
je ne dis pas qu'ils s'aveuglent
complètement en faisant fi des
inégalités sociales non non non mais
simplement qu'ils sont obligés de croire
au moins un minimum à l'ide
allez méritocratique sans quoi il leur
serait impossible de donner le moindre
sens à leur action
il a des centres d'intérêts il lui
arrive de dire ou de faire des choses
ils sont pas mal du tout le monde fait
et voilà sous prétexte que de temps en
temps ben oui il fait quelque chose de
positif heureusement on laisse
tranquille sans fonds c'est là dans un
moïse tout seul et puis en fait rien
voilà c'est quoi c'est acheter la paix
sociale ton très classe et cela ne
signifie pas qu'ils ne font rien pour
garantir l'égalité des chances au
contraire de grandes réflexions sont
justement de mener sur des formes de
pédagogie active qui repose sur
l'explicitation exhaustive de sorte que
les attendus scolaire ne repose pas sur
des sous-entendus que les élèves
devraient apprendre dans leur famille
mais justement ces professeurs conscient
des limites de l'institution qui se
jette corps et âme dans les innovations
pédagogiques ne sont ils pas finalement
ceux qui essayent le plus de faire vivre
l'idéal méritocratique en d'autres
termes ceux qui jouent le plus le jeu
peter berg heures souligne lui même que
paradoxalement c'est précisément quand
on a des doutes sur notre rôle social
que l'on va bien souvent l'embrasser
avec d'autant plus de ferveur
il écrit ainsi même les gens les plus
intelligents lorsqu'ils ont des doutes
sur leur rôle dans la société s'implique
davantage dans l'activité qui leur pose
question plutôt que de prendre du recul
le théologien qui doutent de sa foi pris
d'avantagé va plus souvent à l'église
l'homme d'affaires à qui la poursuite
effrénée du gain donne quelques
scrupules se met à aller au bureau même
le dimanche
le terroriste qui a des cauchemars se
porte volontaire pour les exécutions de
nuit et ils ont raison d'agir ainsi le
rôle forme et façonnent modèle l'action
et l'acteur il est très difficile de
faire semblant
dans ce monde en règle générale on
devient ce dont on joue le rôle et c'est
là je trouve le message de plus
intéressant parce que il ne suffit pas
d'avoir conscience de sa socialisation
pour s'en échapper
ce n'est pas parce que nous avons
l'impression de garder une grande
distance avec nos rôles que cette
distance existe et la distance critique
peut parfois être justement le signe
d'une incarnation total il est très
difficile de faire semblant dans ce
monde
et c'est là qu'une est pour moi une
réflexion sur le jeu d'acteur parce que
nous sommes bien là face à des gens qui
justement font semblant quand il a fini
de torturer un jeune adolescent ralph
fiennes redevient une personne tout à
fait adorable et enchaîne avec un
personnage beaucoup moins magnifique
[Musique]
legrand irene lannister a fait des trucs
qui nous paraît très étrange et quand il
a fini de tuer brutalement la moitié de
la mafia russe
keanu reeves redevient la star
hollywoodienne la plus sympathique et
avenante du monde
bien sûr il existe des exceptions en
particulier certains acteurs sont
particulièrement connu pour incarner un
type de personnage à l'écran et ne se
font plus castet que pour ce type de
personnage mais outre ces cas
particuliers
on observe aussi les acteurs qui
semblent sans limites
capable de tout jouer du rire au drame
du gentilhomme et chants de l'intensité
à la légèreté et on serait bien mal aisé
de trouver au sein de l'acteur lui même
l'impression au fer rouge de chacun de
ses rôles pourtant certaines
performances peuvent parfois paraître
plus vrai que nature
comment imaginer arriver à une telle
justesse tout en gardant une distance
avec le personnage
pour explorer cette question on va
s'intéresser à une évolution de la façon
de jouer des rôles au cinéma qu'on
appelle basiquement en français la
méthode mais que vous connaissez plus
probablement sous le nom de method
acting et on va regarder un peu plus en
détail comment le method acting as
changé la façon dont certains acteurs
approche leur rôle au cinéma à paris
photo richard bouhet et or what is going
to be you need you to be le method
acting sert souvent à désigner la
préparation de certains acteurs qui vont
très loin pour incarner complètement un
personnage comme robert de niro qui a
passé un mois à exercer le métier de
chauffeur de taxi dans new york avant de
tourner le film taxi driver j'ai fait le
parallèle entre le travail de l'acteur
et du sociologue car ils essayent tous
les deux de comprendre les manières
d'agir
eh ben on pourrait placer le method
acting dans une tradition méthodologique
qu'on appelle l'observation participante
popularisé par wigan pou toi et tes
dents street cancer society
cette approche consiste à s'immerger
complètement dans un milieu pour mieux
le comprendre de l'intérieur
outre les immersions dans un milieu où
dans un métier on entend aussi beaucoup
parler d incroyable transformation
physique auquel se soumettent des
acteurs comme kristen bell qui a perdu
28 kilos en trois mois pour apparaître
complètement décharné dans le film the
machinist tout ça avant de prendre 30
kilos de muscles à peine un an après
pour le batman begins de christopher
nolan est bien sûr une espèce d'aura
mystique entoure parfois ces immersions
l'exemple le plus parlant étant sans
doute la performance de risque ledger
dans son rôle du joker pour laquelle il
s'est enfermé plusieurs semaines en
écrivant à la première personne dans le
carnet du joker outre le fait que sa
performance extraordinaire lui a valu un
oscar à titre posthume
on s'en souvient surtout parce que
l'acteur est mort d'une overdose de
somnifères et d'antidépresseurs peu de
temps avant la sortie du film ce qui
naturellement a fait naître la légende s
ledger the re effet emporté par la folie
de son personnage 6e narrative
fonctionne bien
une version plus prudente de cette
histoire serait sûrement de dire qu'au
fur et à mesure que ses insomnies et sa
dépression se sont aggravées il a
dépassé la quantité de médicaments
prescrite
mais notre appétence pour les histoires
nous pousse
justement à brouiller les lignes cela
dit on a également vu naître une dérive
autour du method acting avec des acteurs
qui ne cherche pas seulement à être
juste mais surtout à cela péter
hollywood regorge d'histoires à provo
d'acteurs comme marlon brando ou jim
carrey qui ont fait de l'avis de tous
leurs collaborateurs un enfer
ralentissant le tournage ou piquant des
crises de colère parce que c'est ce que
ferait leur personnage
la dernière incarnation en date étant
sans doute la version du joker de jared
leto pour laquelle il restait
constamment dans le personnage offrant
des cadeaux bien dégueu à ses
partenaires de tournage comme des rats
crevés ou des serpents vivants oui smith
dira d'ailleurs que pendant toute la
durée du tournage il n'a jamais
rencontré jared leto mais uniquement le
joker est de fait quand on voit ces
dérives on est en droit de se demander
si cette méthode d'imprégnation a
vraiment pour but d'offrir une bonne
performance ou si ce n'est qu'un caprice
de star à la mode pendant un tournage
préfère qu'on m'appelle uniquement par
le nom de mon personnage ça me permet
d'investir davantage dans l'histoire
jésus les deux façons régime je suis
toujours un peu meilleur quand je reste
dans mon personnage
d'ailleurs si n'importe quel acteur un
peu moins connus se permettait d'être
aussi chiant et se fraie dirait dès le
premier jour on laisse faire mais pour
bien comprendre comment on a pu en
arriver là ça va être intéressant de
regarder d'où le method acting tire son
origine cette méthode voit le jour dans
les années 50 dans le fameux acteur
studio de lee strasberg qui a formé de
nombreux acteurs comme marilyn monroe
james dean ou marlon brando pour n'en
citer que quelques-uns parce que ils
sont vraiment nombreux à sortir de là
mais pour bien comprendre en quoi cette
technique de jeu était révolutionnaire
il faut se remettre dans le contexte des
films de cette époque on sort tout juste
du cinéma muet le promu films parlants
va jazz singer était sorti en 1927 et
les acteurs sont encore imprégnés des
méthodes de jeu souvent exagérément
expressive qui serait presque à la
limite du ridicule pour nos standards
actuels
et c'est d'ailleurs tout le sujet de
singin in the rain un de mes films
préférés de tous les temps qui décrit la
révolution qui a généré l'arrivée du
parlant dans l'industrie hollywoodienne
et notamment les difficultés d ancienne
star du muet à reconvertir la technique
de jeu dans quelque chose de plus subtil
et de moins exagéré le cinéma est une
distraction qui conviendront mars mai
les vedettes de l'écran n'ont aucun
intérêt pour moi elles n'ont pas textent
à dire pas de senna jouer ce sont des
pantins qui font des grimaces
vous savez et de fait après les années
50 les réalisateurs commencent à
s'intéresser davantage à représenter le
monde ou de façon plus réaliste et donc
la façon de jouer devait changer
également lee strasberg va alors
s'inspirer des méthodes de travail d'un
metteur en scène russe konstantine
sergueïevitch stanislavski stanislavski
pensait que pour jouer des personnages
crédibles les acteurs pouvaient se
servir de leurs propres émotions en se
rappelant des événements de leur vie
personnelle
par exemple penser à quelque chose de
triste s'il faut pleurer à l'écran oui
c'est quelque chose qui nous paraît
complètement évident aujourd'hui mais
rappelez vous qu'à l'époque c'était
relativement nouveau et lee strasberg a
poussé le truc encore un cran plus loin
en disant qu'il ne suffisait pas
d'extrapoler à partir de ses émotions
mais que les acteurs devaient réellement
refaire l'expérience de ce moment
revivre l'émotion pour donner une
performance la plus crédible possible et
c'est de là que va naître puis se
développer le method acting et
incidemment alors même que des acteurs
comme marilyn monroe et james dean qui
ont eu une vie vraiment tumultueuse
arrive à sortir des émotions
incroyablement juste en puisant dans
leur passé leur mort prématurée d'une
overdose et d'un accident de voiture ont
également contribué à créer le narratif
de l'artiste maudit et torturé que l'on
a vu réapparaître avec ace ledger mais
la méthode va néanmoins se déployer et
c'est même devenu la norme aujourd'hui
qu'on attend d'un acteur qu'il publie
dans ses émotions pour fournir une
performance crédible tient hors la loi
avec un peu de nerf ça y est ça y est
pourtant tapé work il a raison on
reprend début
non certes wallace et servir et là on
commence à toucher du doigt un aspect
que je trouve vraiment intéressant quand
on essaie de s'intéresser à ce qu'un
rôle au cinéma
car il ne suffit plus de le jouer il
faut le vivre
c'était la meilleure performance
d'acteur que j'ai fait toute ma fille
l'acteur le plus verser dans cette
technique d'immersion est sans contexte
daniel day-lewis qui va toujours très
loin pour avoir une grande compréhension
de ses personnages dans le dernier des
mohicans il a appris comment chasser et
dépossédé animaux il a même construit
son propre canot et dans le film my left
foot
il joue un homme tétraplégique il a donc
naturellement pas quitté sa chaise
roulante pendant toute la durée du
tournage il a appris le tchèque pour le
film l'insoutenable légèreté de l'être
et pour le film lincoln il ne se
départissait jamais du personnage
demandant aux membres de l'équipe qu'il
l'appelle monsieur le président en
signant même ses sms par le nom de
lincoln
ce qui soulève quelques interrogations
mais lincoln ayant un petit côté tradi
il aurait sûrement fait partie de ces
gens qui signent leur nom en bas de
leurs sms donc pourquoi pas mais le plus
intéressant c'est que quand on lui
demande pourquoi il fait tout ça
sa réponse est assez étonnante il dit
que ce serait en fait beaucoup plus
difficile pour lui de passer d'un
personnage à l'autre et j'aime bien
cette réponse parce qu'il est plutôt en
train d'admettre faire ça parce que
c'est plus facile s'il faisait ça pour
la fame
il serait plutôt en train de montrer en
quoi son travail est extrêmement
difficile et prenant mais qu'il est
tellement un artiste investi et en fait
il dit plus tôt l' inverse
il y à des acteurs qui peuvent passer
facilement d'un personnage à l'autre et
lui ne peut juste pas switcher aussi
facilement
étant donné que dans la vie comme un dj
peter berg heures on devient ce dont on
joue le rôle
il n'est pas absurde que pour fournir
une prestation authentique l'acteur
doivent dans une certaine mesure se
laisser pénétrer par le rôle et cela
paraît d'autant plus nécessaire pour les
normes profondément ancrée comme les
façons de parler quand elle joue
margaret thatcher dans la dame de fer
meryl streep garder toute la journée son
accent britannique de peur de le perdre
si jamais elle cassait le personnage et
cette appropriation passagère peut même
devenir une nouvelle norme si l'on
incarne un type de rôles suffisamment
longtemps gary oldman qui est anglais
d'origine est particulièrement connu
pour délivrer des accents très
diversifié d'un rôle à l'autre
mais après avoir joué dans une rendement
de
américain il raconte avoir fait appel à
un orthophoniste pour retrouver son
accent britannique
bien sûr cela est également dû au fait
qu'ils vivent désormais aux états unis
et baigne ainsi dans cet univers
linguistique mais il n'aurait sûrement
pas autant perdu son accent s'il n'était
pas un acteur devant jouer des rôles
d'américains du coup la question qui
semble se poser au cinéma aujourd'hui
c'est celle de l'authenticité
est-ce qu'on peut paraître authentique
en faisant complètement semblant ou
faut-il au contraire tout faire pour
abolir la frontière entre l'acteur et
son rôle pour atteindre une plus grande
authenticité entre parenthèses
l'histoire du cinéma regorge d'exemple
un de réaction réel de tournage qui ont
été gardés au montage l'argument étant
souvent que les réactions spontanées ont
tant degré supérieur d'authenticité
justement parce qu'elles ne sont pas
jouer mais vécue par les acteurs ainsi
dans le film les infiltrés de martin
scorsese
jack nicholson a surpris tout le monde
en sortant un véritable pistolet lors
d'un dialogue avec leonardo dicaprio
alors que ce n'était pas du tout prévu
dans script ce qui fait que la réaction
de les officiers 100% authentique
autre exemple dans le seigneur des
anneaux les deux tours si ce cri de rage
de la part de l'héritier des landes il
est si convaincant ce n'est pas
uniquement parce que aragorn ledune d'un
de 87 ans pense que ses compagnons
hobbit sont morts mais aussi parce que
l'acteur de 42 ans viggo mortensen vient
de se fracturer deux doigts de pieds en
shootant dans la tête d'or qu elle
par conséquent entre la recherche
effrénée du cinéma pour une certaine
forme d'authenticité et notre penchant
naturel pour les histoires tragiques
d'artistes maudits on peut comprendre
pourquoi la frontière entre l'acteur et
le personnage peut parfois
considérablement se brouiller mais selon
moi cette tendance se trouve aujourd'hui
accentuée par deux aspects relativement
nouveau premièrement la sérialisation
des supports et ensuite le développement
du marketing
premièrement donc on a vu se développer
de plus en plus de séries qui s'étale
sur des décennies et dans lesquels on
voit des acteurs jouaient toujours le
même rôle ce qui favorise leur
sédimentation à long terme dans nos
esprits et ce phénomène est loin de
s'arrêter au monde des séries avec sun
ford par exemple est presque devenu le
prototype de l'acteur des années 80 qui
reprend tous ses rôles iconique trente
ans plus tard et on peut retrouver le
même genre de phénomène avec les acteurs
qu'on a observé grandir comme le trio de
la saga harry potter
ce qui crée de facto une continuité
entre la vie des acteurs et celle des
personnages et bien sûr ce phénomène
mais que trop visible dans la
sérialisation infinie que nous en donner
les films marvel avec des acteurs qui
jouent le même rôle sur de nombreuses
années le grand champion en la matière
est en sont d'autres hugh jackman qui a
campé le personnage de wolverine pendant
pas moins de 17 ans depuis la sortie du
tout premier x-men en 2000 jusqu'au film
old man logan en 2017 avec pas moins de
sept films et quelques caméo bien
senties comme fort
mais cette sérialisation s'est aussi
faite avec un développement de plus en
plus prégnant du marketing qui joue à
fond la carte des parallèles acteurs
personnage en particulier l'entreprise
disney marvel à un nombre de clauses
mirobolantes quand elle engage en acteur
pour un rôle
outre les clauses de confidentialité le
studio fait constamment des recherches
sur les acteurs pour s'assurer qu'il ne
prenne part à aucun scandale qui
pourrait rejaillir sur le studio et
comme les acteurs sont censés
représenter des héros exemplaire leur
contrat stipule clairement qu'ils
doivent respecter un certain niveau de
dignité dans la vie à la fois pendant le
tournage mais aussi à l'extérieur
c'est évidemment un pour éviter les
scandales du type kevin ce pays si qui
se fait accuser de harcèlement pu virer
de la série house of cards et effaçait
numériquement du film qu'il était en
train de jouer
mais le fait que les acteurs marvel
doivent servir de modèle pour les plus
jeunes accentue encore ce phénomène et
cela influence à long terme la façon
dont ils sont perçus par les médias et
comme le storytelling ça fait vendre
on ne s'étonne pas que l'histoire d'un
robert downey junior qui s'est détourné
de la toxicomanie
peu avant d'enfiler le costume d'iron
man est été racontée maintes fois en
dressant des parallèles entre son
histoire réelle et l'évolution de son
personnage qui passe de vendeurs d'armes
à sauveur de l'humanité
[Musique]
on voit donc comment des rôles peuvent
avoir des effets durables sur la vie des
acteurs essaient sans mentionner les
entraînements intensifs qui modifient
durablement leur corps pour leur faire
acquérir les dimensions de surhomme
et de fait ça donne envie d'y croire de
la même façon que certains dé rôle que
nous jouons peuvent plus ou moins
façonné notre identité pourquoi n'en
serait-il pas de même pour les acteurs
avec des rôles qui ne laissent aucune
trace et d'autres qui dépose une espèce
de marque indélébile
d'autant plus pour les rôles qui dure à
force de chercher dans leurs émotions
pour être juste peut-être finit-il par y
trouver quelque chose et il n'est
d'ailleurs pas rare d'entendre des
acteurs sortant dans long tournage
raconte à quel point cette expérience
les a transformés une illustration de
cette marque indélébile se trouvant par
exemple avec les acteurs des films
avengers qui se sont tous fait tatouer
un tatouage identique pour symboliser
l'expérience partagée chose qu'avait
déjà fait en leur temps les neuf acteurs
du seigneur des anneaux qui s'était fait
tatouer le chiffre 9 écrit en langue
elfique s'il s'est accentuée ce
brouillage entre la vie de l'acteur et
les rôles qu'il incarne à l'écran n'est
pourtant pas nouveau c'est d'ailleurs
l'un des sujets qui évoque quentin
tarantino quand il dépeint le cinéma des
années 70 ans once upon a time in
bollywood
dans ce film l'acteur en manque de
popularité que joue leonardo dicaprio se
voit conseiller par l'agent joué par al
pacino d'élite et d'apparaître trop
souvent dans des rôles de méchants le
personnage de dicaprio est un ancien
héros de séries télévisées qui cherchent
de nouveaux rôles au cinéma et alpa
chino lui explique qu on lui faisant
tenir le rôle du méchant dans plusieurs
films et séries alors ça permet
immédiatement de faire monter la cote de
l'acteur qui joue le rôle du héros mais
qu à force de perdre ses combats
l'identité de perdants finira par coller
à l'acteur qui joue trop souvent les
rôles de méchants et cela peut influer
sur sa carrière alors dans quelques
années à force d'être toujours le
souffre douleur de toutes ces étoiles
montantes
vous constaterez sans doute une
différence sur la façon dont le public
vous perçoit
entre parenthèses ce passage me semble
clairement inspiré d'une histoire dont
je n'ai pas réussi à vérifier
l'authenticité
mais que j'ai déjà entendu plusieurs
fois et qui colle assez bien dans le
film mythique de 1972 la fureur du
dragon le climax consiste en un combat
épique entre le maître de kung fu joué
par bruce lee est le maître de karaté
joué par chuck norris il est encore
aujourd'hui considéré comme l'un des
meilleurs combats filmés de tous les
temps je ne peux pas vraiment juger de
sa mais en tout cas c'est certainement
celui avec les meilleurs bruitages et on
ne peut bien sûr pas oublier cette scène
mythique d'arrachage de poils d'une
intensité encore inégalé cela dit étant
donné qu'il joue le rôle du méchant
chuck norris perd le combat et la
légende raconte qu'il a toujours
regretté car par la suite tout le monde
n'a pas arrêté de lui dire que le
kung-fu ça devait être plus fort que le
karaté et ce serait la raison pour
laquelle il n'a plus jamais accepté de
rôles de méchants au cinéma
[Musique]
mais justement si on s'attarde trop sur
ses petites anecdotes l'histoire de
robert downey junior l'histoire de chuck
norris les faits tragiques de marilyn
monroe james dean
on peut se retrouver dans le même état
que les spectateurs décrit par tarantino
et oublier qu'ils sont encore en train
de jouer des rôles et que toutes ces
anecdotes ne sont que des
historicisation de la vie des acteurs
qui sont elles aussi fictive est
grandement exacerbée par le marketing
est ce qui va m'intéresser en dernière
instance ce n'est pas tellement de
savoir si les rôles joués au cinéma vont
avoir une influence sur un acteur en
particulier parce que il me serait
impossible de démêler le storytelling
des parallèles qui pourrait être
véridique je veux dire par là que même
des présidents de la république en
viennent à tout confondre comme quand
dans la halle trump a annoncé adoré
harrison ford
notamment parce qu'il a défendu les
états unis dans le film air force one
oui ce sans doute une très bonne raison
d'aimer harrison ford est un oiseau
merveille du coup je vais plutôt essayer
de montrer que ces rôles vont affecter
notre représentation du monde
en d'autres termes la construction
sociale de notre réalité
ainsi en guise de conclusion pour cette
analyse
je vais m'intéresser aux effets durables
que peuvent avoir certains rôles
cinématographiques sur notre société en
général pour commencer je vais m'appuyer
sur un passage du sociologue marcel
mauss d'automne ouvrage les techniques
du corps paru en 1934
pour la petite histoire marcel mauss
c'est le neveu d'emile durkheim et c'est
l'un des auteurs classiques de la
sociologie et d'anthropologie française
dans cet extrait il nous fait part d'un
étonnement qui lui est venue en
observant la démarche des infirmières
américaines
une sorte de révélation me vint à
l'hôpital j'étais malade à new york
je me demandais où j'avais déjà vu des
deux demoiselles marchands comme mes
infirmières
j'avais le temps d'y réfléchir je
trouvais enfin que c'était au cinéma
revenu en france je remarquais surtout à
paris la fréquence de cette démarche
les jeunes filles étaient françaises et
elle marchait aussi de cette façon
en fait les modes de marche américaine
grâce au cinéma commençaient à arriver
chez nous c'était une idée que je
pouvais généraliser la position des bras
celle des mains pendant qu'on marche
forme une idiosyncrasie sociale et non
simplement un produit de je ne sais quel
agencement et mécanismes purement
individuel presque entièrement psychique
je trouve ce passage particulièrement
intéressant parce qu'il décrit le cinéma
comme un vecteur de normes dès les
années 1930
je vous laisse donc imaginer ce que ça
doit être aujourd'hui mais la question
serait plutôt ici de savoir dans quelle
mesure le cinéma nous offre des
représentations à partir desquels nous
nous figurons les différents rôles
sociaux pour reprendre le vocabulaire de
mid les rôles cinématographiques sont
ils inclus dans le fameux autrui
généralisée qui me sert de
représentation du monde social de fait
je ne suis pas très souvent en contact
avec un médecin
mis à part quand je tombe malade par
conséquent il y a de fortes chances pour
que ma conception sociale de comme en
bouche par les réagit un médecin soit
bien davantage tributaire des films et
des différentes séries que j'ai pu voir
sur le sujet que par une observation
réel du monde médical et même si
certains réalisateurs sont des fins
connaisseurs du milieu médical qui
insiste sur la crédibilité de leur
portrait je suis toujours en train
d'observer un acteur qui joue au médecin
et je ne peux pas en tant que spectateur
savoir dans quelle mesure la performance
artistique décrit fidèlement les tos
médical et c'est à ce niveau qu'on va
réellement observées un brouillage entre
les rôles de la fiction les rôles de la
réalité depuis que les façons de jouer
se veulent de plus en plus réalistes à
défaut d'être réel il me semble qu'on
intègre inconsciemment à notre
représentation du monde les rôles et les
représentations issus de la fiction
par exemple si un jour il devient
journaliste d'investigation et que
j'essaie d'en incarner le rôle je vais
calquer mon comportement sur l'image que
j'ai de cette profession cette image
sera certainement inspiré de personnes
réelles que j'ai pu voir à la télé comme
fabrice lhomme et gérard
av louis plenel ou run faro mais cela
dit je ne peux les voir que sur les
plateaux et pendant un temps limité et
le cinéma permettant d'avoir plus de
proximité avec ses protagonistes
il est également probable que je
m'inspire de personnages censés
représenter les personnes réelles comme
michael keaton dans le rôle de walter
robinson film spotlight dustin hoffman
et robert redford dans les rôles de carl
bernstein et bob woodward le film les
hommes du président ou meryl streep dans
le rôle de catherine g dont le film
pentagon papers et il est même probable
que je m'inspire également de figure de
journalistes parfaitement fictifs comme
tintin loïs lane et clark kent ou même
la schtroumpf reporter pourquoi pas tout
ça pour dire que toutes les
représentations du monde auquel je suis
soumis participe à construire une
réalité plus ou moins cohérentes à
partir de laquelle je me positionne bien
sûr elle ne joue pas tout sur le même
plan je sais très bien que les aventures
de tintin ne sont pas une représentation
fidèle du métier de journaliste mais
force est de constater que la remise en
question de mes représentations sera
bien moins forte pour les films qui se
veulent réalistes et il ya de fortes
chances pour que certaines performances
d'acteurs viennent directement nourrir
ma représentation du monde social si je
fais journalistes
évidemment pour être célèbre moi je vais
être connu tu sais pourquoi
pour nick et les concerts quand tu es
célèbre tunique plein de gonzesses et
puis aussi tu bouffes des trucs bien
meilleures ici
en plus étant donné le fait que nous
visionnons massivement des films
américains
nous en arrivons à intérioriser des
normes qui peuvent être très éloignées
de celles qui ont cours dans notre
société
l'exemple que j'aime bien ce sujet c'est
l'image que l'on a du métier d'avocat
parce que justement cette image nous
vient bien souvent des films comme on le
voit dans l'excellent arrête moi si tu
peux de steven spielberg quand le
personnage joué par dicaprio regarde des
films de procès avant de se faire passer
lui-même pour un avocat
au risque de quelques déconvenues
mesdames et messieurs les jurés
ceci est la preuve irréfutable que
l'accusé nous a bel et bien
menti monsieur konnerth ceci est une
audience préliminaire et il n'y a pas
d'accusé et il n'y a pas de jury mon
garçon tel est précisément je pense que
si je vous demandais là tout de suite de
singe et le rôle d'un avocat
il ya de fortes chances pour que votre
première idée soit de faire quelque
chose du genre
et quoi de plus normal on l'a vu faire
des dizaines de fois dans tous les
grands films qui mettent en scène en
procès pourtant vous n'entendrez jamais
un avocat français crier au beau milieu
d'un procès c'est une procédure qui
n'existe tout simplement pas dans la
tradition juridique française et je
trouve assez drôle qu'on est tellement
intégré cette norme que ce soit la
première qu'on réutilise pour figurer un
type de situation qui n'a pourtant pas
lieu d'être
objection objection votre honneur ceci
n'a rien à voir avec une quelconque
agression sexuelle et procréation la
persona palois de sortir des chansons
pendant le truc c'était un petit exemple
parmi d'autres pour souligner en quoi
notre première façon de nous construire
une image des différents rôles sociaux
c'est souvent autant sinon plus en
observant des acteurs qui jouent
incarner ce rôle qu en observant des
individus qu'il incarne réellement
et c'est sur cette fine ligne entre rôle
représentation est mise en abyme de la
représentation que nous nous
construisons chacun notre réalité
sociale
[Musique]
cet épisode de ce silo geek est
maintenant terminée un épisode un peu
différent de ce que j'ai l'habitude de
faire avec seulement de la voix off et
puis une progression un peu moins
balisés que ce que je fais d'habitude
j'espère que ça vous aura plu n'hésitez
pas à me dire en commentaire ce que vous
en avez pensé
moi en tout cas j'ai eu beaucoup de
plaisir à travailler sur ce nouveau
format
même si ça m'a demandé beaucoup de
boulot heureusement c'était le profil
moins que j'ai pas besoin de me lever à
6 heures du matin parce que j'ai passé
quelques heures sur mon programme de
montage
cela dit je suis assez content du
résultat alors pour ce qu'il est source
me suis pas mal appuyée sur l'invitation
à la sociologie de peter berg heures si
vous cherchez une porte d'entrée pour la
sociologie je vous le conseille vraiment
ce petit bouquin parce qu'il est
vraiment très bien fait ça ne donne
vraiment envie de se plonger dans ce que
la sociologie permet de faire en fait
c'est très stimulant parce que ça donne
envie de réfléchir et typiquement moi
c'est en lisant la ce livre là pendant
le confinement que les idées de cet
épisode vont commencer à venir en israël
j'aimerais bien parler de ça et ça et ça
et c'est donc vraiment je conseille pour
ce qui est des sources sûres le method
acting des trucs que je maîtrisais pas
forcément en fait je me suis plongée
principalement que mes sauts dans des
vidéos de chaînes américaines donc
notamment le cga critique vous les
mettrez en lien là quelque part parce
que là pour le coup j'ai carrément
repris leur travail directement même si
après je les remis à ma sauce alors pour
ce qui de l'avis de la chaîne vous avez
remarqué que mon rythme de publication
n'a pas beaucoup évolué donc vous n'êtes
pas choqué par ça cela dit ça pourrait
venir à changer parce que l'ag en je
suis en train d'écrire une série
d'épisodes un peu plus court qui va
revenir un peu plus sur l'épistémologie
des sciences sociales parce en cours
d'écriture mais je suis en train
d'écrire tous les épisodes d' avance
donc il est possible qu'une fois que je
commencerai les tournées il y aurait une
sorte de régularité parce que je pense
que ce serait les formats plus courts
que ce que je fais d'habitude entre 5 et
10 minutes cela dit je ne fais aucune
promesse parce que un million de trucs
se passe entre ce que je prévois de
faire et ce que j'arrive à faire
réellement
donc on verra bien sinon la communauté
continue à s'élargir
nous venons de passer les paliers de
8000 abonnés ça assez extraordinaire
parce que à la base j'avais pas tu
pensais pas du tout que ça pourrait
intéresser autant de monde donc même si
pour certains ça peut paraître dérisoire
pour moi c'est quand même déjà assez
énorme de matière qui est
potentiellement 8000 personnes qui
écoutent ce que je suis en train de
raconter et dernière petite news qui
fait plaisir j'ai officiellement rejoint
le café des sciences le mois dernier
donc j'ai sûrement des petits logos qui
vont s'afficher à droite à gauche je
suis très content de rejoindre
l'association puisque voilà ça va
permettre de créer un petit peu
d'émulation et puis il doit partir
d'appartenir au réseau de vulgarisateur
sur internet ça fait toujours plaisir je
prends je vous ai tout dit alors
n'hésitez pas à partager la vidéo sur
les réseaux sociaux à mettre des pouces
en l'air à laisser des commentaires
je vous souhaite de très bonnes vacances
pour ceux qui en ont et sinon je vous
dis à la prochaine
[Musique]
beau
oh